today's show is all about death and
taxes Republicans have come to an
agreement on the final tax reform bill
and there is a ton of fake news
spreading about it so much
we will separate fact from fiction and
go through the bill then on cultural
death we'll talk about racists the ones
who are still on Twitter the ones who
are purged from Twitter and a glimmer of
hope on identity politics from
flamboyantly gay Italian fashion
designers finally on this day in history
Slick Willy Bubba Clinton gets impeached
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
there is so much fake news about this
tax plan oh my goodness gracious what do
you know about the plan Marshall what
have you heard about the plan you've
heard nothing less cuz you don't read
the news but but what everyone else is
hearing if they're on Facebook or
whatever is that it raises taxes on
everybody right Washington Post reports
why are Republicans raising taxes on
millions of Americans that's Washington
Post democracy dies in darkness Fox News
reporting the same lies here's the
headline they ran in November Senate
Republicans tax plane raises taxes on
families earning less than $75,000
that's a total lie
Washington Post reported the same thing
Time magazine the same thing Matt
Iglesias who wrote that piece for Vox
said quote for those of more modest
means the news is not so good by 2027
after most of the individual cuts in the
bill expire and the corporate cuts
remain households earning between 75,000
and $100,000 will see on average no tax
cut and households earning it less than
$75,000 will see on average a tax
increase the shape is clear
most people are paying higher taxes and
the rich are paying less this is a
complete lie this is a when did you
catch what happened in there did you
catch what he said after the tax plan
goes into effect and then in 2027 this
will change in 2027 he's predicting 10
years out but he leaves that out of the
headline you don't want to include that
in the headline so they're saying that
once we cut taxes now and then if those
cuts expire in 10 years taxes will go up
yes that's right when you cut taxes and
then if if 10 years later they don't
make those tax cuts permanent or they go
or they raise taxes then taxes will go
up but taxes don't go up now they are
cut now but it is true we could say that
any tax cut is really a tax raise if
someone you know any declaration of war
is really a declaration of armistice
anyway it will happen in a future point
we just don't we just can't quite say
when virtually everybody gets a tax cut
now ironically my taxes may increase
slightly this is very frustrating but
it's because I do well enough for some
reason Shapiro keeps paying me and I
live in la-la land where the marginal
state and local tax
rates are approximately 750 percent so
lefties have been saying that the tax
plane is unpopular CNN breathlessly
reports quote public opposition to tax
bill grows as vote approaches in another
article also on CNN of course only
twenty nine percent of Americans approve
of the GOP tax plan now what they forget
to mention is that an even lower
percentage of Americans supported Ronald
Reagan's 1986 tax plan which led to an
uninterrupted quarter century of
prosperity they supported at fewer
people supported it before that was
passed I wonder why that is I wonder why
it just doesn't add up when all
Americans have to go on is mainstream
media reporting they oppose Republican
tax reforms but then when the reforms
become reality though the people like
them because it made them richer it's
and I don't want to go too far here it's
it's almost like saying there's a
difference between the mainstream media
reporting and reality and and further
that that difference is intended to
damage Republicans I don't know I don't
know I'm just spitballing then it's just
what it seems like to me I don't know so
enough about the fake news what is
really in the plan well most importantly
basically everybody gets a tax cut
virtually everybody I might even get a
tax cut depending on how things shake
out the final version of the plan
maintains seven individual income
brackets instead of the four as the
house proposed instead of consolidating
into four and it lowers the rates
slightly to the top rate Falls from
thirty nine point six percent to thirty
seven percent all of the rates basically
fall it's too bad it would be better if
we could consolidate these tax brackets
but c'est la vie everybody's basically
getting a tax cut anyway it just doesn't
make it quite as simple as we had been
promised by consolidating the brackets
the the final bill scraps the personal
exemption but it just about doubles the
standard deduction that's fine that
comes out in the wash it repeals the
Obamacare mandate very very good the
Republicans had trouble repealing
Obamacare on their own there was too
much squishiness in the house and in the
Senate the president Trump pushed for it
but it didn't quite come out so that's
fine we'll repeal the Obamacare mandate
in the tax bill this is really
this will almost necessarily lead to
major reform if not outright repeal of
Obamacare because we've now removed the
funding mechanism for it excellent
excellent news and also this is a matter
of personal liberty an important matter
of Liberty that Obamacare mandate is the
first time in American history the
federal government has said that every
single citizen has to purchase a product
from a private company or there will be
a penalty or a tax or a penalty tax or
whatever you want to call it to get this
thing through judicial review now that's
over this is very good news for American
liberty very good news for returning to
a constitutional framework for our
country now the final bill doesn't
eliminate the death tax that's too bad
but it does double the exemption to it
so I think now it's around 12 million
dollars or exempt before you have to pay
the death tax we should get rid of the
whole thing all of that wealth has
already been taxed at the income the
corporate level the capital gains level
wherever we don't need to tax you for
dying that's a stupid idea but okay
that's fine doubles the exemption very
good child tax credit doubles to $2,000
per child this is also not a great idea
but I understand these people are
working in the Senate they have to go
back to their constituents they want a
little insurance if this is painted by
the Democrats as just a big tax break to
the rich very easy for me to talk into a
microphone harder to face your
constituents fine who cares it limits
state and local tax deductions bad for
me good for the country so in the final
bill it allows a deduction of up to ten
thousand dollars in state and local
sales income and property taxes
previously it was basically unlimited
this is very good for the country
because it under the current tax regime
there is no incentive for state and
local governments to lower their taxes
because it just comes out of the federal
government's basically a federal subsidy
for high state and local taxes that's
not good
what this does is slowly take away that
perverse incentive so hopefully over
time la-la-land my state of California
will get its act together and stop
taxing us into oblivion
the final bill maintains the mortgage
interest deduction for existing
homeowners this was a big demagogic
aspect of tax reform they said if you're
gonna lose the mortgage interest
deduction it
gonna kill homeowners they've allowed it
to remain whatever not a big deal
going forward for people who are now
buying homes they can still deduct
interest on up to $750,000 in mortgage
debt that's down for 1 million this is
not a huge deal basically maintains the
status quo although it's a little bit
better I guess so it's a step in the
right direction
tax breaks for charitable contributions
and retirement savings plans remain we
were told that would go away again bad
for simplifying taxes but probably good
incentives all in all I would much
rather give my money to charities that
do what I want them to do that are doing
the good as I see the good then give it
to the federal government regardless of
what they're doing just a waste because
there's so so much waste and
inefficiency the final bill maintains
medical expenses deduction we were told
or constantly harping on how people with
chronic illnesses would be bankrupted by
this didn't happen not surprised at all
this does not tax graduate student
tuition as incomes that was one thing we
were promised is it was going to put all
of these little graduate students
protesting you know when they're on
lunch break from their Gender Studies
class to protest President Trump or
whatever thing they know nothing about
it was going to tax them into oblivion
which i think is pretty good and
basically what we have done so far is to
subsidize a very bad university system
in this country and that's no good
whatever it's out in the wash they're
not they're not going to make that into
the final bill fine I guess I was hoping
we could maybe try to fix the
universities in the crisis fire
education in the country through this
tax bill but that might just be too
difficult sad now there's no change to
the student loan interest deduction
there's no change to education credits
there's no change to the graduate
student taxation there's no change to
classroom expenses deduction there's no
change to capital gains taxation on the
individual level this tax plan is fine
say levy but what this tax reform really
focuses on is business so the chief
business of the American people is
business that means the deduction for
pasture
income remains the corporate tax rates
drop hugely hugely Bigley from 35% to
21% very very good even Democrats have
gotten on board with this before it was
President Trump doing it now they all
hate it it eliminates the corporate
alternative minimum tax very good the
alternative minimum tax is what happens
where because of the tax code if in one
year the US business has major losses or
something or they're writing off losses
they have to pay a certain amount of tax
that's a terrible idea we should have an
alternative maximum tax but that's very
nice that we're getting rid of it
US business is holding assets overseas
will now be allowed to repatriate that
money at eight percent or fifteen and a
half percent for liquid assets this is
incredible
currently US businesses have two and a
half trillion dollars overseas because
the US had the highest marginal and
effective corporate tax rate in the
world practically now we could bring
that money back it would be a huge boon
for the economy and all of the
incentives are there to do it this is
pretty different from the last
administration let's flashback to Barack
Obama's attitude toward business if
you've been successful you don't you
didn't get that on your own I'm always
struck by people who think well they
must because I was just so smart there
are a lot of smart people out there it
must be because I worked harder than
everybody else let me tell you something
there are a whole bunch of hard-working
people out there
if you were successful somebody along
the line gave you some medal there was a
great teacher somewhere in your life
somebody helped to create this
unbelievable American system that we had
that allowed you to thrive somebody
invested in roads and bridges if you've
got a business that you didn't build
that somebody else made that happen
didn't you know didn't you know if you
have a business you didn't build that
somebody else made that happen I didn't
know that but that's the major shift all
in all this simplifies the tax code so
right now
taxpayers spend nearly 7 billion hours
just to comply with the current tax code
an amount of time which is worth two
hundred and thirty or two hundred and
sixty three billion dollars thirty
percent of people filing their taxes
itemized them so they break down the
little things are going to deduct that
it creates mountains of paperwork with
this now higher standard deduction that
number of people who itemize their taxes
will drop to under eight percent by most
analysis thirty percent to eight percent
that's gonna save a lot of time more
than 30 million taxpayers will save time
the National Taxpayers Union foundation
estimates that the drop in itemizing
alone justjust that will save 210
million hours in compliance burdens
that's a savings of thirteen billion
dollars annually this is a big big win
sadly it could be a way bigger win on
individual taxation but all in all great
stuff I'm not gonna complain this is
really really good stuff all around
despite the net constant negative press
qoph FA okay we've got to talk about
cultural death but before we get to
cultural death let's let's talk about
the thing that resembles death but it
isn't death because you get to wake up
in the morning now be sleep now sleep is
very very important as you can tell I
haven't slept in days because I would
flew back to New York over the weekend
and I've moved around a bit I moved for
you from New York up to Connecticut and
then back to New York over to LA every
time I move I get a new mattress Natura
shopping is truly awful it was really
really terrible there are a ton of
online mattress retailers popping up
these days
they all offer a one-size-fits-all
solution to a better sleep so I would
always go into the stores and to get a
mattress that experience is dreadful if
you look online they they just have this
one-size-fits-all but guess what one
size doesn't fit all
he likes sleep offers something that
does not exist anywhere else it is a
mattress personalized to your unique
preferences and sleeping scale that will
not set you back thousands of dollars so
what do you do go to helix sleep calm
slash Knowles KN o WL es take their
simple two to three minutes sleep quiz
and they will build a custom mattress
that will be the best thing that you've
ever sleep slept on now two to three
minutes that is the maximum amount of
time that I will do anything that is
just that it's the maximum I'm a
millennial I don't want to move I want
to sit at my computer and I have a DD I
can't focus on anything for more than
three minutes luckily it will not take a
lot of time for couples they'll even
personalize each side of the mattress
and net this is very important because
for me and my fiance sweet little Lisa
we have a particular sleep pattern I
prefer to sleep on a mattress that is
hard and she prefers to sleep on a
mattress that I am NOT on so you can
personalize it it's very important
because those are incompatible sleep
preferences
everyone from GQ to Cosmopolitan to the
New York Times are all talking about
helix and once you try it out you will
know why so your custom mattress arrives
direct to your door in a week shipping
is completely free try it for 100 nights
if you don't love it they will pick it
up and refund you in full that's a
pretty good deal there is no risk
whatsoever go to helix sleep calm slash
Knolls KO wles like Beyonce right now
you will get $50 towards your custom
mattress Merry Christmas that's my
Christmas gift to you $50 for two custom
mattress it's very important where you
sleep is very important you're gonna
spend a third of your life on it I spend
about two thirds of my life sleeping so
make sure that it's good helix sleep
calm / Knolls KO wles for $50 off your
first order helix sleep calm / knowles
okay enough about sleep we got to wake
up we got to wake up people to our
terrible culture so there's actually
some good news and there's bad news on
our cultural death death and decay let's
start with the bad news and then we'll
happy now this is all around bad you
might have seen if you were tweeting
yesterday Twitter is further clamping
down on free speech
very bad it's purging its platform of
racists only a specific kind of racist
probably stupid but whatever but it's
only those specific racists that's very
bad again first of all if we're going to
purge Twitter users and purge Twitter of
anything how about we focus on I don't
know Isis
maybe Isis would be that'd be nice if
he's slightly more urgent than some
dummies in their basement tweeting out
articles about IQ as if that means
anything to society or to culture now I
was blocked recently by a verified user
that's where you get the little blue
checkmark his name is Kevin Allred he's
a professor of Beyonce studies that's a
thing I'm not this is not a joke he's a
professor of Beyonce studies he tweeted
F white America F white America all
around a very anti white things and he's
still around
they haven't purged any of the anti
white racists of course so the people
who are of other ethnic backgrounds they
get to say whatever they want about
white people and there's no backlash
that isn't surprising that part I'm not
suppressed at all the Twitter has this
double standard if Democrats didn't have
double standards that have no standards
at all what is surprising is that there
is apparently no rhyme or reason even
among the pro white racists as to who
stays and who goes so they let a Richard
Spencer he's the famous one who has the
fascist looking haircut and we got
punched in the face on the street they
let him stay they let David Duke stay
David Duke who's almost Revere Yulin
racists in the country but they kicked
off Jared Taylor Jared Taylor is this
guy he basically comes off as Bill
Buckley without the wit or wisdom but he
has this lockjaw accent and he
pronounces the word white as who Wyatt
Oh what I'm I'm an activist for the
whole wide people and it really doesn't
make a lot of sense they're letting
these other guys stay on but not him and
now if you're gonna clamp down on racism
if Twitter's gonna have a policy that it
won't tolerate race mongering race
baiting language it should apply that
rule fairly to all racists of all
varieties all ages and all races Jared
Taylor perhaps unwittingly puts this
issue into stark relief we are
on completely opposite sites on the
contrary they get away in a way we are
mirror images in that you are fighting
for your people I'm fighting for my he's
talking to Univision host Jorge Ramos
and he is exactly right
he is precisely right they are mirror
images they're mirror images of one
another the these race baiters on the
left and these white race baiters on the
right on the alt-right or whatever
they're mirror images but that's not a
good thing I wouldn't go bragging about
that I wouldn't ride home and boast and
say yes I'm a mirror image of Jorge
Ramos if I looked in the mirror and I
saw Jorge Ramos I would smash the mirror
I would throw it out that's a terrible
idea
but they are they have the same premises
this is why the alternative right is in
many ways much more like the left they
have a lot of premises and a lot of them
are ground themselves in post
Christianity racism is very stupid it's
very stupid I know it seems sort of edgy
right now and it seems taboo because
their twitter is banning white racists
but it nevertheless it's very very
stupid Richard Spencer wrote in his
alt-right manifesto quote race is real
race matters race is the foundation of
identity now race is real I guess that's
true race matters maybe I let certainly
that's less true and racist the
foundation of identity that isn't true
at all that is not true at all if people
might think that that's the sort of
thing that adolescents think you
remember in high school and you're like
13 or 14 you try on all of these
personalities so you try paint your
nails black and you're really gothic and
then you're a skateboarder and then
you're wearing popped polo shirts or
whatever you try on various identities
that's what's that's what children do
but there is an answer to this and in
the West there's an answer and it's
explicitly not race for everybody that's
true but especially for the West because
in the West we ground our identity in
Christianity in Christianity they give
us the exact answer the the animating
force of the West and that answer is we
see it in Moses when he talks to God
Moses says who
or you and God says I am that I am and
we see it when Christ is speaking to the
Pharisees they the the Pharisees say
you're not even 50 years old how could
you possibly be older than our father
Abraham and Christ says before Abraham
was I am
when you lose your grounding of identity
when you disconnect it from the I am the
essence the metaphysical the divine
logos from the I am then you're left
with a pathetic question which is Who am
I and you try on all of these stupid
ideas so I could say what am I am I
essentially a conservative am i
essentially Italian American descent am
i essentially a mathematician
am i essentially this or atomizes
special essentially a hula hoop dancer
no all of those are trivial they're
ancillary the question of race is just
like that unfortunately these guys like
Taylor and Richard Spencer and David
Duke they never got past that age that
adolescents they never matured into
adulthood to answer that question as a
serious person does which is the essence
of my identity has to be greater it has
to be transcendent it can't be a trivial
and physical aspect of my own body or my
own being now on the bright side of
culture there is a glimmer of hope here
we have Stefano Gabbana of Dolce &
Gabbana so Gabbana recently said in an
interview basically just this who's
doing an interview with the Italian
newspaper the Cordillera that della
Serra and he said the family is not a
fad in it there is a supernatural sense
of belonging I'm just surprised at how
still to this day people call me gay he
is a gay guys in relationships with men
but why he says in reality I am a man
gay in reality I am a man the word gay
is just a word an invented word that is
used to identify people but I don't want
to be identified or classified based on
my sexual choice homosexuality has
always existed it's not new I'm not gay
I'm a man that's it
a Blaise Pascal said similar things by
the way he he wrote in his pond say and
the thoughts of Pascal one of the great
geniuses of the modern era he said no
man should be known by his book which is
pretty bad
do get known by that blank book and
sometimes no man should be known by what
he writes they shouldn't say you're a
mathematician or you're this or you're
that the only it be a gentleman be known
as a gentleman this is more encompassing
only be known ultimately by that which
is totally transcendent and infinite and
all-encompassing the I am rather than
these stupid little categories that that
try to take what is a great thing
mankind and fit him into a little box
which is ideological and and stupid
Gabanna understands all of these little
ancillary denta fires are trivial
they're insufficient really good stuff
that's a that's a an excellent mark for
those Italian fashion designers gotta
love those Italian conservatives they
have a good a good sense of the world
and now let's move on to this day in
history before we move on unfortunateiy
in history today this day in history is
when Bill Clinton was impeached it's
gonna this left his tears tumblr is
gonna fill to the brim as it did 20
years ago 19 years ago but if you're not
on the daily walk calm right now you
can't see the whole rest of the show if
you're on Facebook or YouTube you got to
go over to daily whiner calm thank you
for those who are already members helps
us keep the lights on in here if you're
not already members sign up it is $10 a
month or $100 for an annual membership
what do you get you get no ads on the
website you get me get the intro Clavin
sure you get the Ben Shapiro show blah
blah blah there is this day in history
19 years ago for Bill Clinton was
impeached by the House of
Representatives for being a dirty rotten
lying sexual deviant so if you want to
be able to celebrate that and not drown
in all the lefty tears especially now
that the Clintons are totally dead
politically you have to go to the daily
wire.com you can have those leftist
tears
hot or cold always salty and delicious
daily wire calm right now we'll be right
back
are we ready now Marshall can I do it
now can we get into Bubba now we can do
it okay it's time for this day in
history this day in history what a great
day I remember I was just a wee little
lad on this day in history in 1998 but
Bill Clinton was impeached for lying
under oath to a federal grand jury and
obstructing justice let's roll the clip
House Resolution 6-1 for resolved that
mr. Hyde mr. Sensenbrenner mr. McCollum
mr. gikas mr. Kennedy mr. buuder mr.
Bryant mr. Chabot mr. Barr mr.
Hutchinson mr. kanin mr. Rogan and mr.
Graham our appointed managers to conduct
the impeachment trial against William
Jefferson Clinton on this vote the yeas
are 228 the nays are 206 Article one is
adopted
sad sad for bill now why was he
impeached I did not have sexual
relations with that woman
these allegations are false but then
about five minutes later he admitted
this indeed I did have a relationship
with Miss Lewinsky that was not
appropriate in fact it was wrong it
constituted a critical lapse in judgment
and a personal failure on my part for
which I am solely and completely
responsible 'unless led people including
even my wife that was quite a change now
how could Bill Clinton make both of
those statements with a straight face
it's because he's also the guy who said
this dude
your relationship with Miss Lewinsky
there was no sex of any kind any manner
shape or form the president claimed what
utterly false me it depends upon what
the meaning of the word is it depends on
what the meaning of the word is is it
unbelievable watch that when he's
referring to is when he told his aides
there's nothing going on with Monica
Lewinsky now he was following the
classic mob advice of deny till you die
so Bubba explained himself he said if is
means is and never has been that is not
that is one thing if it means there is
none that was a completely true
statement now if someone had asked me on
that day are you having any kind of
sexual relations with Miss Lewinsky that
is asked me a question in the present
tense I would have said no and it would
have been completely true ah completely
completely true he says completely true
Slick Willy Clinton so he got impeached
Clinton was the second president in
American history to be impeached for
charges were considered there was
perjury obstruction of justice a second
perjury and abuse of power the first two
passed the house decided not to pursue
the second two so he lied
about a year and a half long sexual
affair with Monica Lewinsky a 21 year
old intern who when he was 49 and 50
years old so Democrats tried to play it
off as some little fling Clinton's
associates and his wife and campaign
managers smeared the women as bimbos and
trailer trash but remember this isn't
some fling we're talking about the
president of United States and his
employee who was 28 years younger
certainly young enough to be his
daughter
consider for a moment the performed
anger right now that we're seeing from
Democrats at Roger Ailes Bill O'Reilly
even Matt Lauer Charlie Rose on and on
and on what they did doesn't hold a
candle to what Bill Clinton did all of
those guys doesn't hold a candle to what
Bill Clinton did among the more lurid
findings of the embed
stationed against him or Bill Clinton's
creative use of a cigar on the lowest
level staff member in his employ
sometimes a cigar is just a cigar but
not for Bill Clinton and of course
Lewinsky wasn't the only accuser even at
the time of the Lewinsky affair former
Arkansas state employee Paulette Jones
was suing Clinton for sexual harassment
including his exposing little Bubba to
her in 1991 uninvited former White House
aide Kathleen Willey accused Clinton of
groping her without consent in 1993
imagine imagine them we just saw this
Frank and fake resignation but at least
he had to go through it imagine that in
1993 Clinton admitted an extramarital
affair with Jennifer flowers he's had
variously documented extramarital
affairs with countless other women and
Juanita Broderick then a nursing home a
had claimed Clinton raped her so
viciously that he made her bleed
nevertheless Clinton was acquitted
ostensibly because Democrats concluded
that I did not have sexual relations
with that woman really meant yes I did
have sexual relations with that woman
you know I mean it may I understand how
you could get confused now it was a
party line vote basically for Democrats
who were joined by a handful of squishy
Republicans including Susan Collins
Orleans Specter and Olympia Snowe we can
draw a few lessons from this affair
first of all Republicans should not
squish stop squishing the Democrats
don't squish they don't do it there was
a party line vote Republicans shouldn't
do it either there's no reward for doing
it do we look back with pride on the
legacy of olympia snowe we look back
there's gonna be a big statue to olympia
snowe how about arlen specter no I don't
think so go big or go home Winston
Churchill explained why he would
continue to fly after his third plane
crash a nearly fatal plane crash they
said aren't you gonna stop why are you
doing this you should stop fly he says I
love life but I do not fear death me too
speaking of me too only now that the
Clintons are no longer politically
useful to Democrats is the party willing
to raise a ruckus over sexual assault
convenient timing very cynical timing
that's another take away the cynicism
Democrat politics are always at all
times
cynical the party of slavery of the KKK
of urban destruction of appeasement of
disloyalty and division very cynical
party don't believe them some pearl
clutching
Republicans think we should be wise as
doves and innocent as serpents that will
not turn out very well for us we have to
be wise as serpents and innocent as
doves FBI agents last year texted about
an insurance policy in case Trump won
they had that conversation in the office
of the director of the FBI
Democrats have called for impeachment
since last November simply because they
don't like this president and they
really don't like how effective he has
been this investigation about Russian
collusion may have been started just to
stop Trump from getting elected that's
what a lot of evidence shows now
Republicans better not let themselves
get played for fools okay I always love
when history relates to the present so
it's nice and we can learn some very
important lessons from that okay that's
our show today tune in tomorrow
I'm Michael gnosis is the Michael Hall
show get all of your mailbag questions
in for Thursday we'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017